good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and happy Tuesday hope everybody's
having a great day I'm joined by my
co-host who is stealing my Luke or are
you stealing my Luke we're wearing the
same Luke Combs different sweaters but
similar enough that I think will look
really nice on the YouTube today maybe
you should mosy on over to see these
gous girls let me tell you the funniest
thing that happened to this I've been up
since the crack of dog I am today is the
day the movers come pack and load the
truck tomorrow they deliver everything
to the new place and so I've just been
up you know doing a million things I did
start a moving Vlog while I said I
wouldn't do
a home tour I will do a moving Vlog so
you can see like a a lot of people ask
for an empty apartment tour of my old
place yeah that's fun sure and then
you'll see like a sneak peek of the new
place just a little bit I like everybody
was so everybody was so respect
respectful I'm like wait you don't want
it that's all you had to do I was
posting on Instagram about my move and
how the movers were there and so I was
like I was hyping up the moving company
that I use which is roadway you use them
and I was like they're so fab Jackie
used them to move to Florida somebody
dm'd me she was like wait Jackie lives
in Florida how does she do the
toast we are killing it with our YouTube
setup with our YouTube setup but maybe
they're just a podcast listener and
nothing's changed for them right right
we've got the sure premium microphones
we've got the roadter we could be
anywhere in the world La we should be
anywhere in the world if you could be
anywhere in the world La where would you
be at this very moment yeah in my new
apartment with everything unpacked and
all my furniture delivered like the
journey I have ahead of me is very
daunting and overwhelming so if I could
just be at the end of it you're a few
days away from your dream that's really
not bad some people are years away if
that that was
me that was you I'm just saying dreams
in general yeah and especially for
Californians because they're the elk of
dreamers yeah that's so true they could
wait a lifetime for for a dream like
this yeah so true I'm so glad you
brought that up yeah California is don't
stop dreaming don't stop
dreaming um so that's like just a little
bit about me crazy moving girl new
apartment yeah she's just crazy for
change that lot turd that lot turd is so
crazy for change my book club met last
night I want to hear all about it
because you guys read the measure which
was a redheads book club book we read it
back in March I really liked it I
thought it was a great Book for a book
club so I know you didn't like it but
how did the book club discussion Go
mixed reviews all around I would say
three out of five didn't like it two out
of well we were missing two members so
three out of five liked it two out of
five didn't we're usually a group of
seven um it did spark interesting
conversation I did listen to the
redheads episode before so I could have
like some fire talking points you know
mhm um I was hoping nobody else listened
to it cuz then they would know I was
like regurgitating other people's
brilliant ideas and I don't think anyone
did thank god um it was a great book
club we ate I always eat so good at book
club that's why we call ourselves the
babus to book club because we got a
homemade meal every time and last night
was no different we had bolones we had
steak story we had a roast chicken with
rice he went made three Entre it was so
good I saw and then my friend Rachel
made her famous chocolate chip biscotti
cookies like I I left like with gas
that's good but I want to hear more
about the book and the discussion
so the general consensus of the book was
like none of the characters were
interesting AG we didn't like we didn't
like any of the characters like the the
one we all agreed that we liked best was
Ben I was going to say Ben yeah but even
then like he wasn't great or compelling
so we didn't like the characters um we
did argue over like fate vers Free Will
um but the general consensus that we
came to is that it really felt like the
writer was trying to say something it
felt like she was trying to make an
agenda no not an agenda she was trying
to make a statement about something and
we literally couldn't figure out what it
was you know
yeah yeah to me and this wasn't for
everyone and certainly not what the
writer had intended um cuz she literally
wrote it before kind of the coid madness
but for me Dana and snitch like it was
the book on coid it was about the
vaccines it was so analogous like I
couldn't see it any other way even
though she literally explicitly said
that's not what this is I didn't see it
that way I brought that up and nobody
else saw it that way nobody saw it that
way wow no a lot of people like thought
of
Co but they didn't think of like the
short stringers and the long stringers
as people who got vaccinated and people
who didn't we I think maybe it was a
statement like on discrimination yeah I
think so but I don't feel like it was a
very well um like it wasn't clear what
her message was from the book I think it
was about like discrimination
marginalized people the treatment of
people okay really didn't come through
for me yeah I understand that I just
when I finished the book I I was like
what is the point why did like what was
the point of this book well definitely
makes think C it wasn't
entertaining okay I really didn't like
it I'm I'm sorry to hear that I did like
it I really did I I think about it all
the time like since cuz I'm just like
always thinking about the string not
always thinking about it but so many
things bring me back to the string
concept no I haven't thought about it
since we did um agree that it was like a
good book club book it sparked you know
interesting conversation and we're just
really struggling like we have not had a
book since the rose code that everybody
liked or even like most people liked
we're in a rut and for our next book all
everyone in my book club is Jewish and
we were thinking of doing a book on
Israel just so we can like you know
learn but we all agreed like that's a
little boring
like yeah
you could do something that's like
adjacent to Israel like you know why
there's a need for Israel sort of thing
like about people like immigrating but
also you guys probably know a lot more
than the average reader because you've
like grown up with it yeah so we haven't
picked a book for next month but it was
a great meeting of the crew and by the
way we've had three babies born in our
book
club sorry two excuse me but the next
book club Margot will most likely miss
because she's du any day now so
we're just kind of like like a really F
we're like a
traditional book club well we would know
it by the name I do feel like the name
sums kind of gives it away you're just
like childbearing eating cooking women
yeah no no we literally are in the ' 50s
we should have read even though everyone
in the book club has already read it but
as a group we should have read lessons
in chemistry because like that book was
for us I'm obsessed with lessons in
chemistry I haven't watched it yet I got
the pr package from HBO and it was
really really cute except I was boo it's
on Apple sorry sorry to the PR Company
yeah it was Apple um I it came while I
was in New York so it didn't really work
out but they sent a lasagna bullones in
like this LL Bean cooler bag was a
kosher no and it was rotten by the time
I got home yum I couldn't have eaten it
anyway but it was a cute idea and it was
a it's this huge cooler bag it's the
coolest bag it says supper at 6 they it
came with like a notebook for your
recipe some like um alcohol-free wines
it was so cute that is cute I'm just
obsessed with lessons in chemistry and I
just don't want to watch it because like
it's something I'll always have to look
forward to we talked about it at book
club because a lot of people were
annoyed that it's being released like
one episode at a time so some people had
started it some people had not I think
everyone in the book club has read the
book um but we were talking how we we we
didn't think it was like an amazing
casting for Brie
Larsson
the she's never going to be my Goto you
know what I mean but she's a solid
citizen like for me it would have been
like January Jones you know cuz that's
oh my God it would have been January J
she's someone like you can get really
excited about like I personally don't
get like so excited about Brie Larson
but she's just like a great solid
actress and she'll be very good yeah um
you just reminded me that when about PR
packages I don't know how to do this in
any other way and I just feel like a lot
of the girlies who work for like Brands
and PR companies listen to the toast I'm
moving so if you have an address on file
for me like don't send stuff there
anymore like if you need my new address
we'll get it to you but just don't send
any more boxes please I don't know how
else to get that message across people
like post that on their Instagram
stories influencers I've seen yeah I
just feel like that's not going to hone
hone in for people like I think the
toast is really kind of transformative
in that way I think that's great I hope
that all your boxes get where they need
to go oh God me too which eventually is
in the garbage because you're the
sweeper I am the
sweeper um I swept literally update from
yesterday with with the closet
organizers and the decluttering girli is
Ben did an amazing job we literally I
own half of my Earthly possessions now
than I did yesterday I feel so light and
then when the movers came like there's 1
million boxes and they like are just
getting started I really I have so much
crap yeah there's a lot of boxes but
that's also cuz they you know pack
sparsely and they give space for
everything they make space yeah don't
like sometimes you see so many boxes but
there's not like so much in them yeah
that's true it's okay okay they like to
make space and leave space for everyone
they like to make space yeah so that's
my moving update Vlog is in process and
it's very exciting week for me how's
everything going with you Jax mother of
two back at work full-time things are
going well go being back at work very
exciting um speaking of Vlogs I actually
just posted a vlog this weekend that
people are kind of loving it was like my
book launch week Vlog and it started out
like really excited so much excitement
and then just like little by little
chipping away at that until you know the
excitement completely petered out after
October 7th um but it was a journey and
I do like a really big try- on haul of
like all these authorial looks a little
postpartum conversation about how I'm
feeling where I'm at what size jeans I'm
wearing um brave brave brave yeah just
cuz I don't know I was just like feeling
like chatting to you you were feeling
brave no I don't even feel like it was
Brave okay I just feel like it was
real real
real and there's another Vlog on the
patreon we both did Vlogs we actually
it's going to be a vlog heavy month but
that's just because there's so many
exciting things happening in our lives
this month um I had a vlog right before
that trying on close for La which was
traumatizing so lots of try-ons lots of
girly swirly action on the patreon yeah
the people love the trions it's the
worst like for the person filming it
there's no uh worse experience for the
people watching it there's no greater
experience so we do it for you and then
we have some other episodes Brewing this
month I'm really excited about and
that's really exciting I can't believe
October is almost coming to a close it's
zoomed by zoomed by in a Flash I'm
looking forward to the end of year
because it's the best time of year MH I
have a new apartment where I could see
the snow by Christmas but it is making
me sad like my year of yes wasn't that
yesterday it was yes today I'm almost
one year into to saying yes and then
next year what will you you say no
really no I don't know I have enjoyed by
the way saying yes to life I would
recommend
it so you'll say yes again next year no
I'll have to reevaluate where I'm at at
the at New Year's you know yeah make I
don't want to make any blanket
statements resolutions yeah well it's
very exciting the holidays are coming up
so FES the greatest time of year and
it's here help me CBR
Joy to the World and everyone lift up
your lights there's a favorite that's
like an underrated holiday Bop like
everybody knows Kelly Clarkson but what
about Ali and AJ honestly they know it
it's there it's rated I feel like people
give it the props it deserves I mean
it's that time of year again where we
we're non-stop going to be talking about
Kelly
Clarkson's album Christmas Spectacular
it's so good I can't wait to like go all
in wonder I wonder what Kelly has up her
sleeve this year for holiday she always
does something remember last year was
the the big NBC special with all those
guests Ariana Grande yes and she put out
another holiday album I don't know if it
was last year or the year before
hopefully she's got some some big plans
on her
patreon she bet Kelly needs a patreon I
would sign up in a second I just like
want her to cook for me yeah and she has
like she's very homey cuz she has that
you know Wayfair Furniture line she has
you know the kids the Christmas song
she's kind of like a Martha Stewart in
the making children's book
right yeah it's time Kelly patreon.com
Kelly
Clarkson after patriot.com theeast
after after how are the stories today
they're good um Britney is taking over
the news I don't think we're talking
about her today but her book did come
out today so there's just like a million
stories Bombshells from the book I am
going to read it I started the new
Sophie canella book which I'm just like
not really loving right now and I read a
really similar book last year so I'm
like kind of regretting having started
it but I love Sophie canel she's my
favorite author so I'm going to push
through then I have to read the redheads
book which first Thursday of November
reading the dead Romantics read along
with us it's like spooky season who
picked it Rebecca I never heard of it
it's like a new book it's a comedy like
a romcom but also a bit spooky perfect
for Halloween and then I will read
Britney's book so I'm a little backed up
I suggested to the book club that maybe
we try a memoir since we're just kind of
like striking out with every select and
nobody was into the idea I was brutally
rebuffed I would read Britney's book for
the redheads but I know Dana is the next
pick and she's not going to pick that
definitely not I wouldn't even one her
to because she always pick like leads us
into interesting territory yeah yeah and
her end of year book her December pick
is always like the best book of the Year
bang out we had Addie laroo Midnight
Library horse mat at Midnight Library
was one of the worst books what you're
crazy I couldn't even finish it it was
horrible it was so short my God so
[__] depressing it was a little
depressing but it makes you think I've
just had enough with thinking you know I
know I feel that way so I'm like I'm
going to read a Mindless book and now
I'm reading a Mindless book and I'm like
well this is a waste of my time okay
that's so real I literally flipflop
between World War II books and
pornography and every time I'm reading
pornography I'm like this is such a
waste of my intellect and every time I'm
reading World War II I'm like my God
this is [__] depressing yeah like I
just want to keep it light and bright so
true it's so hard to be such an Avid
Reader and an intellect yeah it's it's
just hard to find like books that like
walk the middle line that are like
entertaining and also good quality reads
also I think the more that I read like
the higher my bark of course I feel like
last year I probably had like 10 or 15
five star books this year I might have
two but that's also because when you
were a new reader everyone recommended
the five star books to you and you read
them all first and now you're like going
through the fours and the three stars oh
my God that's so real like we all read
luckiest girl live crads Evelyn
Hugo first and everything else just kind
of like pills in comparison it's so
true yeah and I'm like I'm I just want
everyone at Goodreads to know like I am
on to you I am on to you and you're
fraudulent ways I think good I need to
look into like who owns good reads
because Amazon no I'm telling you it's
Jeff a publishing house has to own it
and they're hyping up their books that's
s like do you know how many like
Goodreads famous books I've read that
are some of the biggest piles of [__]
I've ever read in my life well that's
just like book world no I'm telling you
Goodreads is like a industry plant oh my
gosh don't say that I love good reads
and I use it in a i engage with it in a
very genuine and authentic way I'm on I
was lit on it this morning all of their
users do like the users aren't the
problem I'm telling you like people go
to Goodreads with the purest of Hearts
it's the people at the top that are
starting stuff no and Goodreads does
have a gap in their product in terms of
book recommendations like I say I like
they're always like recommending like to
Kill a Mocking Bird it's like that's
just not what I want to read and like
when you go to like lists like okay so I
have my favorite genres here let's click
historical fiction it is like the oldest
list of books from like the last 20
years like where's the fresh ones no and
on Amazon when you go to a movie one of
my favorite things to do is like if I'm
in the mood to watch something like
Nancy Meers is I'll go to like the
holiday and go to customers also watched
and that algorithm is amazing every time
I look I find what I'm looking for
Goodreads needs that for sure you can
find it on Amazon the thing is tury not
to toot our own horns but like we
actually really
um influence
that section like when you go to any of
the books that we love if you went to
like customers also read it's like all
the other books that we love I know it's
like a circle jerk of the same books cuz
we started the jerk we did that's so
like our influence is just like too vast
I'm seriously like not even kidding like
if you wanted to read um something
similar to Evelyn
Hugo or luckiest girl live would come up
yeah like it's all the books well Evelyn
Hugo everyone loves but I'm just saying
like even some of the random books we
like then it's just all the other books
that we've recommended no we're too
powerful for our own good and it's like
who recommends to
us that's what I'm saying where do I get
my recommendations I get them from uh
the redheads like Community listeners I
get them from Dana too she reads a lot
and she'll tell me like something that
she thinks I would like I get my
recommendations from you having said
that I think now that I'm like more of a
Avid Reader and I have my particular
likes and interest
I don't think your recommendations serve
me anymore like I think we have really
different
styles yes but I feel like I don't
recommend that much to you because I
think a lot of what I read like I know
you wouldn't like right so I'm kind of
out of recommendations for you yeah I I
don't know where to go for
recommendations book recommendations are
really hard I feel like there are so
many places for TV recommendations but
not books cuz it means someone has to
sit and read it and that's why are so
personal like that's also why people
like you know follow Reese's book club
or Oprah
but it's kind of Hit or Miss over there
but it's also just personal yeah and
it's just like sometimes it's not the
vibe sorry right for one person but
another another person's favorite book
can be someone's like literal like zero
star piece of [__] yeah that's so yeah
you have to follow book clubs even like
Emma Roberts has her book club and we've
overlapped a lot um and I've read like
some of the books that she recommends
like per chance but she's a little
sometimes not my vibe I can't explain
what the vibe is but it's not mine
sometimes the vibe is
personal that's why you have to create
your own book club and but even I
created my book club and like we're in
our flop
era yeah that's but anyways that's what
I'm saying like that is an app that
needs to be made where it's like a
better generator for recommendations and
like
Community shared interests no and
they're not you know pushing product
from publishing houses that they
own I owns good reads cuz I know you can
connect your Amazon I don't think Amazon
owns it I'm telling you penguin Random
House like some big publishing company
I'm onto something Goodreads is an
American social cataloging website and a
subsidiary of Amazon that allows
individuals to search its database of
books what publishing house is to Z's on
own oh that's a what Publishing House
guys I'm telling you I'm like I I know
I'm on to something
they probably own a
lot they have Amazon publishing yeah and
like Kindle unlimited like they have a
lot of Kindle exclusive authors does
Amazon have a Publishing House no
not Jackie they're hiding it why the
penguin Random House merger is also
about Amazon I literally told
you the US wants to stop penguin Random
House from buying Simon and Shuster the
elephant in the room is
Amazon
this is giving
younger totally whatever like whatever
it is I know it's buried in paperwork
and shell
companies penguin Random House owns
Goodreads you heard it here first good
reads shut up I hate
you um should we dive in yeah might as
well dive into the fast five stories
that you need to know and the fast five
stories that you need to know are
brought to you by sax.com we are always
doing our best when it comes to looking
fabulous on the podcast sometimes our
pajama uniforms and sweatshirts shade do
need a little bit of an upgrade and
that's why we love shopping at sax.com
for everything from podcast luks to gno
outfits and more so if you're looking to
get your summer wardrobe you know your
capsule wardrobe in check sax.com is a
fabulous fun and flirty place to shop
they have all the best designers that we
know and love and they're also really
Fab at discovering new upand cominging
designers that you can get before
everyone else does and then you're the
coolest girl in town sex.com is super
fun and easy to shop on so whether
you're going for a cozy fall Vibe a more
elevated look they've got it all at
sax.com and it's really easy to shop
they have different categories you can
shop by occasion so if you're going on
vacation or you need like work luks you
go to a conference maybe you've got a
crush on your cooworker you need a cute
Blazer suit they'll help you out with
their fabulous fun easy and fresh way to
shop uh you can also shop they get
really specific you can shop by your
star sign so they're making it easy for
you horoscope girls you can find the
perfect Revenge dress from Brands like
Christopher esber and cult Gia I love
discovering new brands at sax.com
they're also just amazing they have
great customer service they have great
shipping it's also just h a big database
I hate when you're shopping on on
websites and you literally like get to
the end of the product you know you can
never get to the end of the pages at
sax.com like there's just endless so
discover new ways to shop for everything
every day at saks.com that's saks.com
thank you saaks for sponsoring today's
episode today's episode is also brought
to you by better help do you ever feel
like your brain is getting in its own
way like you know what you should do you
know what's good for you but you just
cannot seem to do it well therapy helps
you figure out what's holding you back
so you can work on yourself instead of
against yourself so if you're thinking
of starting therapy why don't you give
better help a try it's done entirely
online it's designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and switch therapists any time for no
additional charge that is in my opinion
one of the best things about better help
because so many things about inperson
therapy can be really awkward especially
if you don't Vibe with your first or
second or even third therapist which is
totally normal cuz what's more personal
than therapy nothing um they make it
easy so it's like not awkward you don't
have to go and call and cancel they'll
just switch you and then you could talk
to your next therapist uh whatever
Medium you're most comfortable with so
you can text you can video call you can
uh regular phone call like back in the
day so whatever you're most comfortable
with whatever you can be the most honest
with always never a bad time to start
therapy and better help is an amazing
affordable and very accessible option so
make your brain your friend with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com toast
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com toast betterhelp.com
you know if you're trying to fall asleep
at night and your thoughts don't stop
racing put those thoughts to bed therapy
is always the answer today's episode is
also brought to you by seed seed's DS1
daily symbiotic is a plant-based
Prebiotic and probiotic with 24 strain
that has been clinically or
scientifically studied for its benefits
it's free from 14 classes of allergens
defined by efsa uh sugar free it's vegan
it's soy free it's Sesame free it's
gluten- free it's peanut free it's ampa
free dairy free shellfish free corn free
so if you've been wanting to start
taking a Prebiotic or you've take taken
one in the past that hasn't worked for
you seed is the best in the business you
take two capsules once a day on an empty
stomach and it's engineered to survive
your external and internal environments
their capsule and capsule vacap
safeguards viability through digestion
for delivery of an average 100% of your
probiotic starting dose to your colid so
there's so many benefits you know for
your digestive health a lot of benefits
for your skin you know if you're not
making the best duties you're not
consistent maybe they're a little sharp
you want to make a big soft Duty check
out seed also the skin health is really
um fabulous because similar to your gut
your skin has its own microbiome and
your skin is home to trillions of
microorganisms and their byproducts
collectively known as your skin
microbiome so get it together like get
on a Prebiotic probiotic seed is a place
the ds01 daily symbiotic you can avoid
gut Mania and head to the trusted source
for symbiotics start a new healthy habit
today visit seed.com toast and use code
toast to redeem 30% off your first month
of seeds DS1 daily symbiotic that's seed
SED
d.com toast and use code toast
T at seed.com toast to redeem 30% off
your first month of seeds DS1 daily Sim
biotic thank you Claude you're welcome
our first story Kim Kardashian is
launching skims for men she dropped the
ad campaign yesterday featuring athletes
like Brazilian soccer star Neymar D
Silva Santos Jr NBA star Shai gilgas
Alexander of the Oklahoma City Thunder
and NFL defensive end Nick Bosa of the
San Francisco 49ers bang bang party Lou
um I saw this like and I gasped I was
obsessed I love Nick Bosa not enough
people talk about him he's literally the
hottest man alive I didn't know him and
I'm like part of bang bang ners game I
really only know him because of his
thighs like have you seen the thighs
they were actually talking about his
thighs on the broadcast last night you
know him from his size before he was in
his undies yes where did you see his
size like anytime they're on TV Jackie
they're the biggest things just Google
Nick Bosa thighs I'm not going to Google
that I'm going Google Nick Bosa and see
if his thigh stand out to me okay
because it's giving you know Tessa
Bailey novel okay I'm on my way images
they're like
enormous yeah but like don't all really
all football players have like big
thighs yes his are I believe to be
extraordinary I can't with you H we were
talking on the phone yesterday is this
man single and if so is he dating Kim I
mean I have to imagine if Kim was onset
they definitely went for dinner like I'm
sorry you just can't be around someone
that hot yeah oh wait it looks like he
had a girlfriend when was
this in 2021 we're safe yeah it's like
if they're not engaged by now like
they're definitely probably not together
I love that skims launched for men I
think that's really really smart um I
like that she got creative you know
skims is an international brand so I
don't know this Brazilian footballer but
I'm sure he's like a huge deal well the
name Neymar is a big name in football
but then there was a junior so I'm
wondering if this is like the son of a
of the big Neymar or if this is Neymar
himself the Son of a Preacher Man the
son of a big neyar literally um I wish
she did like a few more people three
isn't enough we were also saying that
who she needed to have in this campaign
was David Beckham now I'm sure the
campaign was shot before beckam Mania
but skims is really good about turning
around like people who get famous
remember when they did the two girls
from White Lotus like the day they got
famous they're really good about turning
[__] around I would have loved and David
is friends with Kim and Victoria's
friends with him and she was just at the
show sitting next to David like
theorizing her men's drop knowing he has
a documentary coming out it was honestly
a little bit of a Mis opportunity plus
it would bring in an older generation of
men like but do you think that him doing
a shoot for like another company is like
a conflict of interest his wife like she
makes clothes for women yeah I guess I
guess I guess but he might like you know
have already an underwear sponsorship
for sure by the way for sure I'm sure
she's actually pretty limited and who
wasn't contractually tied to another
underwear company like Kelvin Klein or
even like Nike yeah you probably
couldn't do also skims because it's not
just undies it's shirts it's apparel
yeah yeah yeah that's actually really
good point she kind of had to go with
these untethered people also it looks
like Neymar is the Neymar he's the
Neymar the Neymar that's so that's a big
deal in the soccer World I loved this I
also I did watch a 49 this game last
night and I have some harsh thoughts for
one Brock tury Brock per Jack he stunk
it up like he lost the game for everyone
he threw two interceptions like they had
that Fighting Chance at the end then he
threw this interception and you know
what they still had a chance literally
20 seconds left they they could have
made a touchdown if they wanted
to but you're saying they didn't want to
interception Brock so it wasn't even
close it wasn't even close it was almost
like maybe he needs glasses cuz the guy
he we threw to like wasn't even close to
what of his actual teammates maybe he
thought that guy was on his team so
here's what I think it's different with
a quarterback CU they really are
responsible for how the game plays out
but like if one person is responsible
for like you winning or losing like what
about the rest of the team agreed like
when David Beckham when they didn't win
that World Cup because like David was
out of the game it's like well what
about the rest of the team like where's
the accountability for you guys you
can't win a game without this one player
and we're all going to be mad at the one
player who's been apparently winning
every game for you yeah quarterback's a
little different but I do agree with you
wholeheartedly and I will say the San
Francisco 49ers defense was not
defending in the way that they needed to
they weren't defense no damn so it's
just an off night and I I don't think
it's right to blame it all on Brock
turoo yeah but I hear what you're saying
he wasn't playing beautiful football
because we we keep saying for the Super
Bowl like it's going to be either the
Chiefs Eagles or the 49ers and they were
all 5- one last week so they're even the
Eagles as of this week are six and one
the Chiefs are 6-1 and now the 49ers are
5-2 okay I understand your
disappointment tur but they're allowed
to like have a one bad game it's two in
a row and as long as it's not I was just
watching the Kelsey documentary and the
Eagles had like a a bad couple games
right before they made the Super Bowl
too so it's like it's going to be okay
maybe they'll it's good to work these
things out now make the mistakes now I
just I want more for my friends on the
team I don't know if I've mentioned like
I'm actually really friendly with with a
lot of the players like we're kind of
like lifelong friends me and Kyle and
George and like I just I want more for
them you know it hurts cuz you're an
empath it hurts it that's the thing it's
hard to be a football fan when you're so
deeply empathetic yeah to both teams to
players on both teams no and I know how
hard my friends Kyle and George I know
how hard they work you know year round
and I just I want I want them to succeed
cuz that's the type of person I am like
I lift others up who did they play last
night like some losery ass teams sorry
no offense the Ravens Minesota oh yeah
wait no sorry I got the colors they're
both purple Vikings they're actually not
a losery ass team um they're fine but
like their record was like two and five
so like they are
stinkers and you know relative to the to
the to the league yeah it should have
been an easy game a team that's five-
one is playing a team that's one in five
like where's the logic yeah maybe
there's greatness on that team that was
another thought I had when I was
watching Beckham when like he went to
Real Madrid and every great player in
the world is on Real Madrid and then
they start like losing or they and they
lost their first game and it's like well
I want to watch a documentary about that
other team because looks like there's
greatness over there big week for them
yeah like or no maybe they're just an
incredible team it was like mayorca they
just like always beated them and I'm
like maybe I should be watching a
documentary about mayorca they always
beated them they always beated them I
love sports like I can't believe I
wasted so much of my life like not being
interested in it um I kind of watch go
to the Jets game this
Sunday cuz I'm obsessed and I love the
Jets like that's my team that is that's
where you've landed that's where I've
land well I have a I have many teams
let's not forget 49ers like but I'm for
my home team people are always like
Giants Jets it's Jets yeah I feel that I
don't feel um sympatica with the Giants
I don't know them me neither I think it
was because our dad was a Jets fan yeah
our dad was also a Mets
fan that's tougher yeah because like
when it comes to Mets and Yankees like
the Yankees are just fabulous they're
like the richest team in the MLB they're
so historic you know they were on
Seinfeld George castanza worked for them
like they're so New York no and it's
like we have two New York teams one is
incredibly good and one is incredibly
bad why would you electively root for
the bad team by the way that's like not
the case anymore that was the case when
we were growing up but the me I feel
like it's more so the case than ever the
Yankees are always like World Series
adjacent even if they don't make it to
the Jackie that was literally when we
were in middle school they were like in
the world Lally like two years ago no no
no the Mets aren't the Mets and World
Series haven't been uttered in the same
no no but the Mets have peed Alonzo and
Mike
Patza and Matt Harvey I think no he's
down and out I don't think he works
anymore H
jealous so Nick B and his that's what I
was saying I just love sports like I
need to get more and Ben's like now Ben
is really excited cuz he comes home and
like I'm watching football and Ben
doesn't love football he's really into
basketball he's like the Nick start next
week and I'm just like I kind of don't
care basketball doesn't do it for me no
basketball's it's not as relaxing as
football it's kind of frantic no the
most frantic is hockey like how in the
[__] are we supposed to see that puck
it's tiny and it moves so fast and also
the the field is smaller than like a
football field and they go faster on
their skates so it's like we're just
shuffling up and down the field it's
also very
violent
yeah it's dangerous it's dangerous I
like I don't mind hockey though I
actually like hockey yeah I like it too
because you get to wear like a nice
chunky sweater if you go to a game it's
like cold yeah where it's like a
basketball game like you're rubbing up
against people sweating your titties off
yeah something to think about yeah um so
skims men check it out for your mans
looking forward to seeing other mod in
future drops yeah I I I thought this was
smart and I want more mhm agreed
speaking of sports I think they need B
offer
celebrity if they could get him if he's
not already contractually obligated to
gild in those are the types of underwear
he
wear from Amazon well Ben was buying
Calvin Klein underwear and it's
literally a pack of three4
$33 yeah and I'm like I'm sorry are you
the Queen of England like why do you
need such expensive underwear and he's
like because they're so good like the
band is really tight and it like holds
me in I'm like let me just try and I
literally ordered the first one I saw
off of Amazon a pack of like hundred for
$3 he's obsessed obsessed you should get
him skims men cuz they're a sponsor so
reach out yeah okay I'll try I'll try
I'll see if he likes it yeah I'm sure
they're delicious like when Ben was
wearing more expensive underwear than me
I was like there's a problem here agreed
thank yeah our next story some more
sports news Travis Kel's dad Ed is
praising very sweet Taylor Swift for
picking up trash in the suite he said
she's not a diva so Taylor Swift just
got the seal of approval from Ed Kelsey
her boyfriend's dad Ed had nothing but
praise to um for the singer after
meeting her for the first time at the
October 12th Kansas City Chiefs game
talking to People Magazine on Monday he
described Swift as a very very sweet
very Charming down-to-earth young woman
he also noted that Swift's intelligence
comes through right
away he said that um he recalled a very
special moment when he realized Swift
was a very genuine person rather than a
diva he said quote we're sitting in the
suite she gets up and in the front of
the room she gets up to go get a drink
or something and she starts picking up
empty bottles cans plates that are
scattered around because in the Suites
everybody gets stuff and you empty it
down wherever you can and I'm just
thinking I don't think she got the diva
memo she didn't get the spoiled musician
she doesn't know how to pull that off
and that to me really said a whole lot
there's just something so interesting
here that like
if one of Taylor's boyfriends in the
past had their dad to a People magazine
interview I'd be like what the [__]
somebody with the Kelsey is so precious
like they're really just like this
downhome family they're not thirsty CU
they get attention very naturally they
don't need to be thirsty so I could see
a world in which a story like this in
another scenario like would have rubbed
me the wrong way even though he's saying
nice things but something about it is so
precious I think also the anecdote that
he's sharing like if he just spoke to
People magazine to like get his name out
there and say like oh she's nice it was
a fun day like okay get his name out
there yeah I would be like okay sit down
but he's sharing these behind the scenes
tidbits that show Taylor in such a
favorable light but also speak to
like future daughter-in-law Dynamics
like when you meet your in-laws like
yeah you better start picking up the
garbage around like can I the dishes
yeah yeah yeah you put the dishes in the
sink you you know you dry off the dishes
like that's something that you do and I
feel as though him sharing this with all
of us it's something we can all relate
to of like yeah get to work like you're
trying to impress the rents get to work
yeah no it's so relatable in so many
ways and I don't know like the more we
learn the more convinced like Heather
McDonald said on the show toast like she
thinks they're going to get married and
I thought it was so crazy but like
honestly yeah I went from not believing
that these two had ever met to okay
acknowledging that they're like hooking
up and it's like a fun fresh fling to
fully believing like they're getting
married I'm on my way there as well
honestly and I said that that would not
be the case but I feel like they like
each other so much I think their
Lifestyles really complement each other
yeah they say like if you have to date
an athlete scheduling wise it's all it's
best to date a footballer because their
their season's the shortest yeah and
they have one game a week I think the
worst is baseball baseball yeah that's
what I've heard they've one game a week
right like Travis is out and about with
her up until like Friday and baseball
they have like seven games in one city
yeah like it's insane I just learned
about that yeah I know that every
baseball game is a series yeah I told
you that on the toes I know I'm I'm
still wrapping my head around it yeah no
it's
dumb so the subway series growing up I
thought it was a world series between
the both New York teams no it happens
every year and it's seven games the
Yankees versus Mets moronic ironic like
who's coming up with these ideas not us
as if a baseball game isn't long enough
we have to do it seven times just to
make we don't even talk about that
football games are actually lowkey long
too let's be real but I like it so I
can't talk about baseball without
getting this song in my head like root
root route for the home team if they
don't win it's a
shame cuz it's one two three strikes
your rout at the old ball game
it's a gorgeous song like that's the
thing about baseball we can clown on it
but it really is like the most historic
like American like they were playing
that [__] like in the you know 1400s the
Great Depression yeah and like all those
songs like you're singing a song that
the New Yorkers of your used to sing
yeah it connects me to the people of the
past right and also like you know we
want a homer just a little Homer h o
m e are Homer Homer
Homer we want a picture not a belly
it p t c h e r picture picture How does
it go cuz it goes we want a single just
a little single s i s i n g l single
sing let me sing We want a double just a
little double d o u b l double double
double we want a triple just a little
triple t r i p La a triple triple and
then how does it go we want a homer just
a little Homer maybe the h o h o m h o h
o m r n home run let's go by the way
you're right about that you're right
about
that then it's a key change gets crazy
remix oh that's why I like that song the
key change and a remix fre frea FR h o h
o m h o m e r u n home run
T hit one then run by the way no other
sport has songs like that we need to
reevaluate the musical element yeah it
counts for something oh I guess football
has oh Sunday
night okay and you know what um you know
what basketball has OG's will
remember what do what you're going to do
but I know what basketball has at ni on
MSG got it from Rose SE do it just to
get there they also have national anthem
Fergie
version so true can't be cannot be
understated no but no one's got that
Spirit like baseball does and that's
like you're right and that history that
history there is something there
yeah that's
beautiful so Ed Kelsey picking up the
trash so sweet so sweet she's a pop star
and you know a s gly we love yeah and
you know uh trying to impress
daughter-in-law of the future like so so
you know she's taking this seriously
it's so true or she just like naturally
cleans up is a sweeper yeah oh my God we
have so much in common she's a sweeper I
sweep like yeah okay let me ask you a
question when you're out at a restaurant
and you go to the bathroom and you're
washing your hands and they have like
the garbage holes you know like the
counter has a hole in it it's a trash
and there's like water all over the
counter and like people's paper towels
do you clean it up no oh I do that's
unsanitary yeah I
know yikes but I'm like I'm a sweeper
like I can't let that counter you're
sweeper to your core but to your own
detriment sweeping is not serving you in
this instance does nobody else see
that sound off in the
comments I feel like that I thought that
was like a like a universal thing no
that's really like unsanitary cuz still
someone has to like wipe down the
counter anyway so you're just like
absorbing germs for what to help to
sweep it's in her blood it's it's in my
blood she can't turn it on and off no I
wouldn't even if I could are you ready
for our next story
yeah rip to this ship Tom Brady and
Arena shak's relationship has fizzled
there's there's no drama says a source
but the two are no longer spending time
together the pair who were first Linked
In July have gone their separate ways
after their relationship fizzled out
most multiple sources tell people TMZ
was the first to report the news The
Source said was very she did all this to
make him jealous and Bradley Cooper's
seeing someone now oh yeah she's like
she over aborted yeah yeah it happens
yeah no you got when you're that
beautiful I totally understand like you
have to be careful but you got to get
the timing right of like you know of the
user of one person right right you could
push the other far away and that's
exactly what happened IA I feel for her
this girl like she can't cat a break she
cannot get
arrested damn well um Irena was very
attracted to Tom The Source says she
liked dating him it excited her that's
so different of her it excited her
attracted they had fun traveling to see
each other in the end it kind of just
fizzled I mean I didn't think this was a
great love but to like the timing of her
and Bradley like now kind of inversely
becoming single and one of them seeing
someone like that sucks
yeah I just like if a hot take like I
think Bradley Cooper like like I'm like
he like was
handsome the operative R beinging
was like she should have stuck with Tom
Brady she should have I actually just
turned on the hangover the other night
um I watched three minutes but just
enough to like remember that that's how
we kind of were introduced to Bradley
Cooper and he was so like his whole vibe
and his whole brand has changed so much
since that I remember what he looked
like in The Hangover he looked just like
a regular like bro no he was like the
gorgeous handsome one like Zach alfanis
was obsessed with him and he had like
long hair right yeah and now he's like
just a goodlook actor oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah that he the long hair was was
nice
yeah what do you think he was hottest
in I would have to go look at imtb but
obviously American Sniper agreed I loved
that like buzzcut beef patty look on him
yeah that was like that's like my type
yeah are there people who don't find
that
attractive yeah I would say up until
this point Taylor Swift didn't find that
attractive maybe she did but maybe those
guys never were into her so she like
kind of survival method like Cho went
The Artsy route but she was always
singing about the football player who
didn't like her but she was never dating
them because they maybe didn't want to
date like maybe it was out of they
wanted to date her out of
self-preservation no you listen to you
belong with me
like okay that was 17 years ago right
but those sorts of things like they
influence who you
become that's true she might have like
put a wall up because she felt some sort
of rejection from those people yeah I
feel that maybe Taylor should date Nick
Bosa next sound off in the comments do
you not find like big hunky men
attractive if you're a head or a woman
or a gay
man yeah sound off S off are you ready
for our next story that I know you're
going to find really funny what number
is this it's four oh my God no I'm not
ready not and you have to get ready
because this is like literally a turdy
special a tury Dreamscape oh I can't
wait today's episode and the tury
Dreamscape is brought to you by Athena
Club we all know that as weather gets
colder our self-care routines often take
a backseat but this year it's all about
feeling comfortable and confident in our
own skin all year long so when we bundle
up in our cozy sweatpants and long socks
there's nothing like the smooth feeling
of freshly shaved legs plus as the
weather gets colder there's no pressure
around how often we want to be Beach
ready or showing our legs so we really
shave for oursel which is the best so if
you're looking to step up your shaving
game you have to check out Athena club's
award-winning razor kit it's seriously
the best on the market and here's why
first of all it is an absolute steal at
just $10 don't let the fool you the
razor packs a serious punch it comes
with a beautifully made handle and two
extra five blade blade cartridges that
deliver an incredibly smooth shave every
time it also has that magnetic hook that
just reminded me I have to take down
before I move and bring with me to the
new place I love my theena club Razer
shaving my legs just used to be
something I was not interested in doing
it felt like such a chore but now it
really is like fun and flirty and fresh
and I get like smooth legs and Ben likes
it and the Athena Club razor mounted to
my wall makes it so easy the quality of
the shave is a game changer their razor
Glides effortlessly thanks to those five
Precision engineered blades the blades
are perfectly spaced out to let hair
pass through with each stroke and you'll
experience less irritation and less
razor burn which is always a win in our
book so if you're ready to upgrade your
shaving experience switch to the best
razor on the market and show your skin
that you care with Athena Club head over
to Athena club.com grab your razer kit
today and you can find Athena Club
razors at your local Target as well plus
with your purchase of a razor kit and a
blade subscription on their website you
can try their gentle body scrub for free
with code toast at checkout just pick a
plan for your razor kit begin checkout
and add the code toast before placing
your order to automatically add a body
scrub to your shipment trust me you
won't look back happy shaving today's
episode is also brought to you by
Collective freelance work is booming so
many people are taking the leap and
starting their own business but how do
you maximize your earnings minimize your
taxes and make sure you're legally
compliant it can be overwhelming
confusing and it takes time away from
your own billable hours as business
owners ourself like that stuff is not
fun but you absolutely have to do it if
you want to set yourself up for success
and something like Collective takes so
much of that struggle out of the
paperwork so you need to talk to the
experts at collective.com Collective was
built specifically for businesses of one
that are making over $60,000 in profit a
year Collective handles all of your back
office work so you can focus on your
passion not the paperwork and stick
around because we're going to tell you
how they can backdate your ESC Corp and
save you thousands on taxes this year so
Collective is the all-in-one Financial
solution for businesses of one they
handle your business formation your
taxes your bookkeeping even your payroll
plus if you're already in LLC Collective
can retroactively elect your ESC Corp
tax status back to July 1 which could
save you thousands on your 2023 taxes
Collective members save an average of
$10,000 per year on taxes with that
structure and a collective membership
truly pays for itself within just a few
months it's 100% tax deductible so check
out collective.com toast before October
31st to potentially save thousands of
dollars on your 2023 taxes to sweeten
the deal they'll also throw in an extra
$100 when you use our $100 off excuse me
when you use our link but you have to do
it before October 3 first so go to
collective.com toast to get started with
your personal team of self-employed tax
experts and they will also throw in an
extra $100 off when you use our link
collective.com focus on your passion not
your
paperwork thank you Claudia I can't wait
to hear this tury Dreamscape so I don't
know if you've heard this but Elon Musk
said he would pay Wikipedia $1 billion
to change its name to dickipedia after
accusing the website of losing its
objectivity to the biases of higher
ranking editors so Elon commented you
know how they're always asking for money
on Wikipedia which you've shared he it's
one of my least favorite things he said
have you ever wondered why the Wikipedia
Foundation wants so much money it
certainly isn't needed to operate
Wikipedia you can literally fit a copy
of the entire text on your phone so
what's the money for inquiring minds
want to know no by the way Elon watches
the toast I literally [__] said this
people around the world for free write
up Wikipedia Pages they literally do all
the work I don't know what the how
Wikipedia is always asking us for a
dollar for when they're literally like
uh doing like forced labor right so he
said he would give them1 billion doll if
they change their name to dickipedia
and then someone said like Wikipedia
take the money you could always change
it back after you collect he said onee
minimum I mean I'm not a fool
lol no I'm dead that's so funny but I
also need him to use his platform to get
down to the bottom of what they spend
their money on and that's very
interesting that he said like the code
of the website is very simple so it's
not like this crazy elaborate website
that requires Engineers of Plenty right
and also then um X you know how they add
context to tweets so they said the
Wikipedia Foundation is a charitable
nonprofit providing free access to
Wikipedia while a text in English only
copy of Wikipedia is about wait wait you
slurred your words start again the
Wikipedia Foundation is a charitable
nonprofit providing free access to
Wikipedia we know that oh okay so
they're considered a nonprofit because
the website free sure but the toast is
free we're just getting to um what they
use this money for so no but I I want to
I'm sorry I want to focus on how can you
consider yourself a nonprofit because
your product is free Claudia in 2022
Wikipedia had 154 million in Revenue
with $145 million in
expenses you said 154 and 15 45 yeah
what is $145 Million worth of expenses
going towards that that's the
question no I'm so glad someone donated
154 million in Revenue by the way I'm
but is it considered Revenue if it's
donations I'm so glad we're finally
talking about this like I'm a little you
know peeved that I wasn't the one to
start the national conversation about it
because I said it first
however I'm so glad like I've been dying
to talk about it for a [__] minute
there is something weird at Wikipedia
and no one's talking about it but now
they are so now let me ask you I don't
know what their motives are at Wikipedia
I want let me ask you would you give a
[__] what kind of pants son of a [__]
you shot you was wearing let me ask you
I so I said I don't know what their
motives are what they need the money for
but on its face Elon offers you $1
billion to change the name of your
business to dickipedia for one year do
you do it yes one because they're so
committed to their nonprofit which
nonprofits like help people like I don't
know who the [__] Wikipedia is helping
we couldn't even use it as a trusted
source for our term paper so like it's
really helping no one um yes because
then like the dickipedia like that you
get press more Revenue yeah like if Elon
said I'll give you a billion dollars to
change the name of the toast to the dick
for a year [__] I do it for a million
like literally where do we sign up yeah
but how do we get one of these offers
like Elon okay we will seriously change
the name of our podcast to whatever you
want minimum a billion dollars I do that
in a second second how do you get one of
these offers I don't know I think I
don't know what we'd have to do someone
send this to Elon
please I need a cool bill and the thing
is a billion dollars is so much [__]
money and when you think about okay this
is a company that made $154 in $154
million in Revenue elon's offering them
10x that right no it's a great deal like
how do you turn it down just because of
your pride of not being dickipedia right
like a true nonprofit wouldn't care
about the pride they would care about
the profit right that's kind of like
what happened with Twitter and the
shareholders when he made them an offer
that like they couldn't refuse they have
shareholders like who everyone would
accept this deal he overpaid for Twitter
right even though he changed it to X and
made it his own I'm I'm not into X I
will say like I'm still calling a
Twitter X has really grown on me I was
just thinking about it this morning
because I was reading something and it
was like so and so posted to X and
really everyone has just just adapted X
being no they really haven't like like
media companies like for accuracy
purposes they have to say like I was
watching football and they're like make
sure to follow the NFL on Facebook X
like you have to say it right and they
have
like colloquially know yeah they're read
from a script right colloquially okay
maybe it hasn't taken yet but I think
that it's going to and I when I think
about X it is so much more
all-encompassing than the name Twitter
and that's what he wanted to be I don't
disagree with that I just like I I'm not
a habit changing girl we know this we do
know it'll take tury longer than the
average user but I think we're well on
our way like At first I didn't really
see how this Rebrand could happen so
naturally but I'm seeing it happen and
I'm liking what I see I'm liking that
Elon is having the important
conversations on the platform that he
bought like dickipedia I'm obsessed and
also did you see that Elon Musk made
superchargers in Israel free so like if
anyone in Israel during the war like has
a Tesla like the charging is totally
free I did
sorry that's King [__] yeah now give us
the billion next but the thing is I
think he only like does it to things
that he has a problem with I don't know
that Elon would have a problem with the
toast I mean I don't know how anyone has
a problem with us we are such a delight
we are two of the funniest girls and I
know us like offline when I tell you
there aren't two more caring charitable
generous kind girls the fact that we
have so many haters like genuinely blows
my mind we are amazing yeah it's so true
it's it's just
fact so I don't think elon's trying to
you know serve us make us an offer we
can't refuse let's just wants to support
the cause which is come on we we are
patreon become a tra Patron a for-profit
Elon don't you want to see what size
jeans I'm
wearing I know I do
are you ready for was that was a
tury
whatcap that was a tury Dreamscape thank
you had you not heard that yet the
dickipedia thing that he offered them a
bill I think actually they were talking
about it at book club last night huh
because I shared my fun fact about the
superchargers you so you were just
talking about Elon we were talking about
Israel as you do as one does are you
ready for our fifth and Final story I
really am someone else has a memoir
coming out this week who's been
completely overshadowed by Britney but
he's telling his story as well he wait
who John seamos oh actually I did know
that I was never gonna guess that John
seamos is addiction struggles Hollywood
romances and more find out the biggest
Bombshells from his Memoir so John Samos
wrote his Memoir cold if you would
called cold if you would have told me is
what it's called and he's talk
mentioning it all divorce from Rebecca
Roma his journey to sobriety his time on
Full House it seems very um he's a he's
lived a big life I think he's actually
the perfect person for a memoir I think
so too so he talks about his alcohol
Reliance how it picked up during his
time working on Broadway during his ER
days I didn't even realize he was on ER
he went that's so Uncle Jesse he went on
an entire press tour while fully drunk
oh he recalls his scary DUI incident
that led to his hospitalization and
eventually
rehab I forget about a time in the world
where Rebecca Roma and Uncle Jesse were
married and I love Rebecca Roma's
marriage currently with Jerry oconnell
like I think they're the real deal and
when he was on our show he was talking
about how like difficult it is to have
your wife be married to someone who
looks like John Stamos and I forget
about that time because I don't think I
was like a conscious you know purveyor
of Pop Culture
but like the most good-looking couple on
the planet yeah so
he also talks about the heartbreaking
moment he learned of Bob Saget's death
oh yeah um and a lot of big things like
he has a lot of big things yeah so he's
mentioning it all in his new Memoir like
I really feel bad for him cuz like the
timing of his Memoir release couldn't be
worse like Jada pinket was last week
Britney's is this week he really should
have waited one more week yeah but I'm
sure it'll still do well yeah the Full
House like fans are loyal and the John
Stamos fans like he's really acquired a
lot of fans over the years yeah and he's
also weirdly like a very digital person
now he's always used to be in like the
Vlog Squad videos he's good friends with
Josh PE he does a lot of podcasts he's
very um like social in terms of social
media he was in the Vlog Squad videos
yeah he used to like show up a couple
like big celebrities used to be in the
Vlog Squad videos like Howe Mandel was
randomly in them all the time and I
think it was because Josh peek was in
the Vlog Squad Josh peek did a TV show
with John Stamos called grandfathered
and I think that's how like John met the
the crew got it okay yeah that was a
crazy time the Vlog Squad and what's the
Vlog Squad doing now so they've all kind
of broken off in their own paths so zaye
and Heath and Mariah and Matt have their
own podcast then Carly Aon Matt and Mike
have another
podcast um David what's David doing he
has views his podcast I think with right
Jason right and then uh what's his name
Jeff with the I and the CR the
crane yes that's what ended the whole
Vlog Squad is that like David was making
everybody do these crazy stunts on a
crane in this Lake and Jeff literally
almost went blind from it I thought what
ended Vlog Squad was the allegations
against David that too yes yes I forgot
about that um whatever Jeff is like a
very outspoken anti Vlog Squad type of
person I do believe the rest of them are
still
friends and they all do different
projects and they're like friendly with
each other they go to each other's
weddings like Matt just got married
married so a bunch of people were there
but I do think there's like even Beyond
David and like the the bigger people
there's like infighting I remember
reading there was like a a fight between
like a bunch of people I don't know the
the fact that that disintegrated so
quickly was so insane yeah I don't even
remember a time but like I was obsessed
with those videos yeah you were
obsessed well John stamos's Memoir is
out now Britney's Memoir is out the
camper and the counselor is out even
though you literally can't get it
anywhere ch's Memoir is out it's been
out for a while but still you can get it
you can still read the story of the turd
that what should my next book be called
now that I have this nickname well what
would is your next book going to be like
Memoir part two I feel like my next book
I think I would do like a collection of
short stories but once I have more
stories to tell like I need to have a
child you know yeah yeah I love reading
short stories about Parenthood they just
crack me out yeah I think that's what my
next book would be so like come up with
a cute name for me okay we have time no
speaking
of speaking of no we have time we have
time yeah yeah yeah so that's our show I
have 13 text messages I just know shit's
going right like at home oh right you
have things going on in your home I do
have things going on in my home it's
very well said so is that our show that
is our show no one else can claim it if
anybody wants to donate to it or
purchase it the price is a billion
dollars so do it that way you will cool
billion cool Bill Elon and if you want
to come on Elon we would love to have
you love thank you so much for listening
to the toast Morning Show where we
deliver the fast life stories that you
need to do every Monday through Friday
on YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we are
also available as podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so that's Spotify
iTunes Stitch public radio I radi cast
box all the places where you listen to
podcast find us the toast leave a five
star review about how beautiful stunning
and Beyond wickedly talented we are hope
you have an amazing gorgeous Tuesday and
I'll see you tomorrow bye love you bye
bye